Next question, can you elaborate on the directions for the radiation for the apathic drops and the weekly footpaths for radiation? I finished the
minimum full-brain radiate oh
10 one-minute full-brain radiation treatments last week. I did one of each footpath the first
heavy metal one turned out a ton of rusty looking stuff and made my feet achy the second one was
clear and my feet felt normal. So there isn't a there isn't a way to measure the degree of
toxicity from radiation in one's body. You can't measure it. So you have to make some
assumptions. So when you have radiation as far as a treatment like radiation for a tumor or
radiation for a cancer in the brain, you're getting a huge dose of radiation, one that's lethal
to the cancer cells in damaging to healthy cells. Now it may be the appropriate thing to do,
but you're getting a lot of radiation. You're really just doing that literally only if you only
have one session of it. You should probably be on a regular radiation detox for a long, long time.
Let me talk in years. You do 10 sessions or 30 sessions of radiation. You should just think of
that you're always going to be supporting your body to help you detox radiation.
And so using the radiation only a path as it is listed on the label, I would just stick to that.
It doesn't mean you take more of it. It just means you're going to take it longer and continuing to do
detox, foot baths on a fairly regular basis. Once you do radiation, maybe you're doing them
every day. Maybe you're doing them at least three times a week. You're trying to do another regular
basis to help your body detox. And remember, there's no such thing as I'm completely detoxed.
You're never completely detoxed because you're always toxifying yourself.
Maybe you're not getting further radiation, but a lot of people take the radiation drops because
they had x-rays. Good to say, the difference in rad dose from an x-ray or a CT scan compared to
radiation. Radiation therapy is astronomical. So you really radiation therapy, you really get
a huge dose of rad. And you want to think about your continuing to detox at a regular basis.
Back to this question, I knew I would think of it the product that you use for cholesterol is
Bergamit. Bergamit. So Bergamit has been shown B-E-R-G-A-M-O-T. We have a product called
product called Bergavid that could be extremely beneficial for reducing cholesterol. That's a
design for health product. Think about using something like that, completely not toxic, like
statinist, and could help with cleaning out your liver. Also, other things that you do to clean out
your liver, like your cholesterol packs and your coffee enemas. That's again the reason why you do it
is to help your body with detoxification, help your body, your liver get cleaned out. But remember,
if you have fatty liver disease, which is so common, probably everybody has some degree of it,
you may never get those down to what the medical profession considers normal levels.